doug don't be don't start throwing
around these celebrity stories
you went to kid rock's 50th birthday
party in a white turtleneck
looking like shook white up in that
first of minute three other people had
on the same outfit
i bet and i need to whiten up in that
[ __ ] and only one of them was a
woman
okay nick roll some of that footage that
we had hey what what song was kid rock
playing
listen cowboy
uh the longer one if you can happy
birthday
i only got 15 second ones off your story
okay that's all of them
there's one uh yeah this might be it's
about being 50.
[Music]
yeah the next one now did you guys plan
to raid the capital after this
why is everybody white in there
there were people that weren't white
dude they were working
[Laughter]
where was this party at it was that a
ghost guy
david duke hold on this is this is good
i guess
the record shows we defended kid rock in
here remember that you and i are kid
rocky yeah we did with that don't try
[ __ ] on him we're like nah
dawg his whole catalog bangs no it was
awesome and i just felt lucky to go i
uh why did you go i just went man
i got invited and you go you don't not
go to frickin kid rock's 50th park did
you know anybody there
yeah did you recognize anybody yeah i
knew like there was uh some country
musicians that i know that i'm friends
with and there was
um was your boy uh waylon there while in
there
kissing random girls while it wasn't
there no who he was supposed to go but
he had a long weekend he said yeah
which is every weekend he says he's a
little hungover
oh he said i had a long weekend hunt and
i'm like you guys are just standing
there you don't even [ __ ] do anything
who else who else did you see there who
else man
um there was like a lot of like hockey
players there
there was some different musicians there
he lived in nashville
huh does he live in nashville now or
does he live he lives in nashville
wait his son was there his drummer's
black
kid rock's cake rocks drummer yeah she's
black uh
she i i don't know if she was there or
not there were people that were not
white there
yeah did you see a black drummer i
didn't see anybody with drumsticks in
their hands but oh
actually but they were serving chicken
that's awesome
different drums or what they have to for
food was it good food
you know what they had little mini
pizzas to go well let's see this video i
want to see it's going to get down this
guy was good
he looks like he gets down
over under that guy owns some white
sheets
but just for sale
just for sleeping man it's just we're
sleeping but hey that's what the mr
pillow guy says too you know
bro that's what it looks like when
you're in a free state right over here
looks like you guys having fun bro it
was a blast
no covet had a good time yeah i'm trying
to think of what else it was like they
had a really cool birthday cake well the
best thing about the birthday was they
did a fundraiser the first two hours of
it they raised half a million dollars
for the bar stool fun
oh hell yeah so that was crazy so they
did a big fundraiser
and then yeah and then he played that
song that he wrote and the song was
great it was like real self-deprecating
it was like i'm not going to tell oprah
to go [ __ ] herself anymore just like a
lot of things that he was like letting
go over his 50 years did he still do the
cruise ship
thing the kid rock cruise ship i think
just because of kova they had to stop it
yeah it makes sense
but but it was cool man i it was just
interesting he's a legend
yeah yeah he's a freaking legend i mean
all the stuff that he's been i couldn't
even imagine
were you talking to people were you in
the corner in your white turtleneck no
no i was talking about it
you're white yeah who is the pizza you
know white people the country
musician jake owen that is that yeah
he's great yeah he's a great guy
girlfriend
i know him so i talked to him for a
while so that was really cool
um who else was there any chicks
there were some chicks there sounds like
there's a lot of dudes there
i know he named all this sounds like a
real [ __ ] face
with many pizzas and you wore your
sunday best huh
well look
[Music]